[音楽]
db 2分
[拍手]
ん
あった
ああああああ
うっはっはーはっはっはっま
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
はぁ
pou dou dou
はぁっ
ten
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
はぁ
はぁっ
はぁはぁ
ああああああ
はい皆様こんにちは
こんにちははじめはセックスの来ない事を申します
えっといきなりちょっとこんなおっきいを出してちょっとなんやねんこれとあの
びっくりされたかと思うんですけれども
えっとこれはですね実はこの僕は今つけてるこれで動くことによって音を鳴らしてい
ました
これは僕が初めて開発した
プロジェクトで
を取ることによって音楽を奏でるというコンセプトで作ったものになります
はいっ
で今日は
中途半端な第一歩が切り拓く未来というテーマでこれを開発した経験を元にお話しさせ
ていただきます
中途半端
っていう言葉
みなさんどんなイメージがありますかね
中途半端
所が中途半端な奴やなとか
中途半端やかわかんねーみたいな
なんかその中途半端=悪みたいなもうあの
悪いイメージがあ
すごいついているかと思うんですけれども僕は中途分パテのすごいあのとくとして
大事な言葉じゃないかなというふうに思っています
もしかしたら場合によっては本当に完璧よりも中途半端にすべき
場合もあるんじゃないかなと
いうようなことを考えています
先ほどからですね本当に偉そうにここでお話しさせていただいているんですけれども
ほんの3年前くらいまではですねほんと塗装ない
もうダメダメなあの社会人でした
もう仕事にまったくぞねやる気がなくて
で遅刻するわなんかもたらだら仕事するわでもうあの上司からはあのお前みたいなやつ
もう前代未聞やと
思った止めても屁って言われるぐらい
ほんとダメダメなの社会人でした
その時のまあ僕の心境としては
なぜ今この仕事をしているのかなお礼と
自分のやりたいことも
人生をどう生きていいかもわからないまま本当に悶々とした日々を
方少していました
何か自分のやりたいことを見つけるためにちっちゃい時何がスキャったかなというのを
ちょっと振り返って考えてみることにしますねでこれボクちっちゃい方が僕なんです
けれども
どちらかと言うとスポーツは苦手で
どっちかというと a 書いたりとかなんかも作ったりとかそういうのが好きな子ども
でそういうのを思い出してあ俺なんかその何かモノを生み出すような仕事ができたら
すごいハッピーに行けるかもうとようやくここで気づいたんだね
成長していく過程でついこれ大学時代なんですけれども
矢印が奥なんですけれどもだいぶ見た目変わっちゃったんですけれども
大学時代はですねほんとにランスに熱中しました
大学生の全国大会で優勝するくらい軟水熱中して
ダンスとかまた音楽というものが成長していく過程で大好きだと思うようになりました
大好きなものに巡り合うことができました
そういう作るのが好きとかあとは英単菅スキって二つの隙が合わさって生まれた
プロダクトのアイディアがこれだったんですね
これはを取ることによって音を出すと
めちゃくちゃおもろいやむと
あのアイディアを花の時はそう思いました
絶対おもろいからちょっと一回作ってみようと
思ったんですね
作ってみよう
でも当時僕はもう何の経験も知識もなかったです
で自分ひとりで何から始めていいかもわからず実現が100へとした後がまさにゼロの
辞典
からのスタートでした
とりあえず何かやってみるお供で何から始めたらいいかわからないからとりあえずこの
時代
とりあえず検索してみようということで身体の動き
スペースケンイチとかですね
スペース詮索が調べてみますねそして意外に
作り方が載ってますどうやって作っていいかどうか結構乗ってます
もう今の時代すごいですねあのう皆さんは世界中の人が知識を共有してますね
インターネットで海外に乗ってるとあれこれ俺でも使う
作れるぞというのが気付いてこのわけわからんけどこのボードとなんかこういう風
に配線したらいいとかこのプログラムを入れたらいいとかっていうのは載っちゃうんで
その頭にやってみたら意外に体の動きが検知できる装置を作ることができたんですね
これがへ
実験の時のちょっとふざけながら撮っちゃったんですけど
方に巻きつけてこうやって動いてますねそしたら自分の体の動きにはしてセンサーの値
が変動してるというのはわかったんで
これおやおやと自分の身体の動きこうやったら検知できる分野ということがわかります
ここまでは自分でできたか
一人ではちょっと限界感じたんでー
エンジニアのが集まる交流会に参加して
頭よさそうなエンジニアさんをとにかく探しました
で自らが彼ですねすっごい頭よさそうね
はいスマホアプリ作れるんですか当てていっ
ちょっと北公園を作りたいんですけど一緒にやりませんかといってナンパしたんですね
そしたらまあたぶん僕の影響にまああのかもう巻き込まれてええいいですよみたいな
感じで
受け入れてくれました
ようやくチームができてですねふたりチームで開発を進めたと
スマホと僕が作ったのセンサーと連動するのは必要がて人だったんで
それもやったんですけどちょっとまあこれちょっと難しかったんですけどこれも
インターネットに乗ってるから結構簡単にできたと
あとはケース買ってきて詰め込むと完成ですね
プロトタイプ第一号がなんと2ヶ月ぐらいで何もない状態から作れました
これこれ以外にできるじゃないかというのはここでは買って試してみました
音がなんですね豊富動いたらめちゃくちゃおもろいと
恋楽しいとやったといろんな人にあのこれ
チャモロでしょうて見せまくったんですね見せてもらったら
お家には
もう前にそんなもういえばどうせ無理やからん
やめとけとかですね
大学の遠足
の間であいつなんかようわからんことをやりだしたらしいでみたいな
部屋かな
なんか噂が回ったりとか
日本の企業の方に見せてもあのこれ誰が名古屋目使うんですかみたいな
感じで言われてちょっとなんかネタ鼻で笑われた小馬鹿にされたというようなことも
結構あったりして
かと思って一生懸命作ったのに
こんな指定されるもんなんだよッ
違うと思う
これおもろいっちゅうねんと思ってで
とにかく馬鹿にされようが何されようがもうとにかくいろんな人に見せました
そうするとある日キーマンのイギリス人の方に出会いました
その役です神の姿めちゃくちゃせたかったんですけどその方がこれめちゃくちゃ
おもろいやんと
グレートプロパック等というものが英語やか何言って顔がないんですけどとにかく褒め
てくれてるっぽいぞと
っ子れ絶対海外持って行ったほうがいいよと言われましたこれよいいよ
俺の感覚グローバルやん
ん
さんと思いましたはい
英語とか全然知らなかったんですけどもとりあえず海外に行ってその方にこうなんか
玩具業界の方はいろいろ紹介しますね
で海外に行って
踊って見せました
[音楽]
得意なロボットなんそこんだにかして
はこんな感じで
もうあのいろんな方に観てたんですけれども
もうみんなとハイタッチまでない
すごい人俺は面白いということでもういろんなが世界中の方に見せてその勢いでも香港
ニューヨーク
イギリスドイツいろんなところもあったんですねこれをもって
でニューヨークではあのベストオブトイフェアって優勝いただいたりとか
あとはイギリスではテレビじゃ良くなるとかものすごい
評価していただいて
なんと気づけばもう17カ国でリリースして
出荷台数も40まで突破してー
youtube の動画再生回数など4100万回再生されて
覚えではテレビシーンもでやってもらってと
有用なえっと
そんな奇跡を切るんですかっていうぐらいの方同様するぐらいの曲付がなんと起きまし
た
ちょっとこれびっくりましたので
8 sns 上でもまあ海外から反応がありましてこの形はいい
自分の声を録音したこうなんかさの詩で恋します
やめちゃくちゃもあのなんですがめっちゃうれしいですよねこういうあの反応はで
こちらの少年はですねあのクリスマスの良いにプレゼントでこのプロダクトもらった時
のリアクション
[拍手]
はい
以下さあメール姉あが去る表すあるん
いや本当にあのこんな反応
ね知ってもらってもう涙が出るほど本当に嬉しくて
ってバナナきましたねもうあの嬉しくなります
で
振り返ってみたら
僕がやったことって
中途半端だけどとりあえずプロトタイプ手が動くも作ってそれをとにかく店ってのあっ
たでもただそれだけでしたぁホントシンボルにただそれだけしかもやってません
スキルも
僕エンジニアとしても全然中断だしデザイン力も英語力もすごいも中途半端なんすね
こんな言うのも恥ずかしいんですけど全部中弾道ですね
ちょっと平行棒ところなんですけれどもやちょっと待てと
むしろ中途半端なまま突き進んだからこそ
誰よりも早く結果を出せて中途分パナ未完成なプロトタイプだったからこそいろんな人
からいろんなフィードバックを受け入れることができてより良いプロダクトに仕上がっ
ていた
いうふうに思うようになりました
プロだコトづくりにめっちゃおもろいなと
ここでちょっと魅力にとりつかれですね新しい挑戦も始めています
それがなんとこちらです人工知能 ai による自動作曲ソフト
ちょっと何度も難しそうなようなんだけどもシーンとモードを選択するだけで何と人工
知能ちゃんが
曲を作ってくれますあなただけの二曲を作ってくれます
んか
なんだもあるそうなこの音楽
これ実は人間じゃなくて人工知能が作りました
ん
このメロディーとかもしれないこのドラムとか
人工首脳がなんと音楽を作る時代がやってきました
[音楽]
何が言いたいかというと
ほんの3年ほど前まで2ためダメだった僕が今なるとこの人工知能っていうわけわから
ないもの
大扱うようになったんですね
とうとう所の多分僕がた人工首脳って何ですかと
ai って何ですかアイアイっていうんですかみたいな感じのレベルだったと思うん
ですけど
なんとこういうことまで扱うようになったとそれもこれも
3年前何の知識の経験もない中
なんかようわからんけど
あの
馬鹿にされようが我々様が中途半端だけど一歩踏み出して本当よかったなぁと今になっ
て本当に思います
やっぱ完璧なる中とこがいいというふうに思いがありました
もし僕がですよ僕が一流のエンジニアになってからでこう作ろうとですね
あとは完璧に英語を話せるようになってから海外進出しようとか
もっと大きな企業で経験積んでからやろうとかそんな言ってたら
たぶんそんな言ったらね時間だって僕の情熱も冷めていた母もしれないなと
今やんってすごく思います
でも一歩踏み出せがどんどん可能性を広げていって
次のステージネクストステージというに繋がっていくんだなというふうにえっとすごく
今感じています
でもで
完璧な第一歩が未来を拓くんじゃなくて中途半端な第一歩こそ未来を聞い開いていくん
じゃないかというふうに思ってます
なので今後とも僕は中途半端な一歩を踏み続けようと思っております
こんな中途半端な
夏の話でしたけれども皆様の
一歩踏み出す勇気に少しでもつながれば嬉しく思いますご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]